bienvenue à santa clara
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquer dans son
usine on fabrique du papier
il ta mort vais y travailler ils savent
à la traîne la patronne c'est que vous y
voilà
autre nouveau chez vous c'est un château
c'est vrai que c'est un château bouge
plus je t'ai fait des années que
personne n'habite ici j'ai bien fermé
d'accord
il ya 500 ans les conquistadors sont
arrivés à la recherche d'argent ils ont
fermé tous les enfants du village et des
ont brûlé vif
ça va à toi t'es pas trop tendue c'est
comme mon premier jour d'école tu vas
assuré généralement on conseille aux
gens de ne pas mener leurs enfants avec
lui à santa clara mais comment ça il y
en a qui s'inquiètent pour la sécurité
et il faut dire que les légendes locales
ne sont pas très rassurantes c'est un
peu difficile à expliquer mais notre
fille n'était pas cela elle a été
emmenée dans la jungle d'enfants je sais
ce que j'ai vu elle l'a vu aussi
vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous
comptez faire pour la retrouver
hahaha